Speaker 1: All right, as many of you know,
I am fascinated by scams, and it just so happens
that the former president and the current
Republican Party have perpetrated a number
of different scams, not only on the American
people generally, but on their own followers
and donors.
We've talked about fundraising scams before.
One such scam was that after the 2020 election,
Donald Trump claimed to be raising money
Speaker 2: for fighting
Speaker 1: the election results for overturning
the election.
Speaker 2: And you could donate, presumably
Speaker 1: to audits and recounts and whatever
else.
Now that was a scam on its
Speaker 2: face, obviously, because they weren't
going to
Speaker 1: overturn the election, but there
were other layers on which it was a scam as
well.
For example, in the fine print, when Trump
was raising money to overturn the election
results, depending on the promo, you would
look at the fine print and it would say 50
percent of your donation.
60 percent of your donation can be used
Speaker 2: not to fighting
Speaker 1: to overturn the election, but to
pay off Trump's campaign
Speaker 2: debt
Speaker 1: prior to the election.
The scam
Speaker 2: was some pre-check
Speaker 1: boxes when you would make what
you thought was a one time donation to Trump.
One of the boxes that was automatically checked
unless you uncheck it, is that you're committing
to an ongoing donation, even
Speaker 2: though you meant to make a single.
Speaker 1: And the second box was that in
some cases the amount would go up.
Whatever your donation, there would be like
a multiplier of some kind added on in the
subsequent donation.
So that was another scam that they did.
There's a new scam now, or at least it has
returned.
The new scam is that the NRC that's the
Speaker 2: National Republican
Speaker 1: Republican Senatorial Committee
Speaker 2: is running a
Speaker 1: promo called
Speaker 2: Dinner with Trump.
Speaker 1: Now, if I say to you, we are running
a have dinner with me
Speaker 2: promo, would you
Speaker 1: expect me to be at the dinner?
I think so.
If I ran a promo
Speaker 2: called Have dinner
Speaker 1: with my mom.
Would you expect my mom
Speaker 2: to be at the dinner?
Yes, I think so.
Speaker 1: If a celebrity chef like our friend
Tyler Florence runs a Have Dinner with Tyler
promo, would you expect him to be there?
Speaker 2: I would.
Speaker 1: But the dinner with Trump?
Dinner doesn't have Trump.
This is a huge thing.
They're promoting it as enter to win dinner
with Trump.
Do you want to have dinner with President
Trump?
Enter now for your chance to meet President
Trump.
But then you pull out the fine print and it
says a winner and a guest will have a private
dinner with senators Lindsey Graham Tim Scott.
And Rick Scott, that there's no mention of
Trump.
Trump won't be at the dinner for the winner
of the dinner with Trump promo or giveaway.
Judd Legum or Legum has been researching this,
and apparently this is a common scam that
Trump and Republicans ran during the 2020
campaign.
There were all these promos lunch with Trump
in Chicago.
Dinner with Trump in Cleveland.
All of this stuff now.
Is it possible some of these events happened
and Trump had lunch or dinner with somebody
that won the thing?
You know, he had lunch or dinner, but with
some of the people who actually entered?
Maybe.
But there is no evidence that we're able to
find that any of these events actually took
place.
Now I want to be really clear,
Speaker 2: I don't care about the
Speaker 1: people getting scammed here in
the sense that if you're willing, willing
to do anything to help Trump and these Republicans
win, donate
Speaker 2: whatever for a meal with
Speaker 1: Trump.
Arguably you've been scammed merely by the
fact that you're supporting this corrupt party.
Speaker 2: So like missing the dinner,
Speaker 1: it's kind of the cherry on top
of the scam.
But shouldn't there be repercussions here?
Because if you run a lottery and nobody wins,
you just collect the money that's illegal.
When you do giveaways, raffles, et cetera,
these things are governed by a bunch of different
law, and it's taken pretty seriously in most
cases when you are Trump, I guess, or the
National Republican Senate Committee or whatever
it is that
Speaker 2: they're called, everything is a
scam.
Speaker 1: The campaign itself, the promises
that were made but not kept the presidency
itself, the fundraising.
Now even the giveaways are a scam as well.
They should be held accountable.
No evidence that they
are
going
to be.